et
et bien bonsoir bienvenue sur diagonale
bonsoir et loi bonsoir
stéphane bonsoir à tous or diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs encore sur le feu et loi
puisqu'on va couvrir le championnat du
monde encore une fois et le championnat
du monde de new delhi 7 fois champion du
monde filet oui le fameux proverbe un
championnat du monde peut en cacher un
autre et bien c'est exactement ce qui
est en train de se passer puisque
vladimir kramnik est champion du monde
mais prennent games et là nous avons le
champagne officiel de l'institution du
jeu d'échecs et donc la fidh et stephen
la fille des fédérations internationales
du jeu d'échecs dont on a longuement
parlé dans cette émission est donc là
tous les meilleurs joueurs du monde sont
là à l'exception de des deux meilleurs
de kasparov et de crack nique
oui à noter une autre absence au stephen
il s'agit d'anatolie karpov
moi qui ne joue pas non plus puisqu'il
est effectivement en ce moment aux
procédures puisqu'il veut récupérer son
titre qu'il estime que la fidh et lui
aurait enlevé ouais m'enfin là ça il va
y avoir deux titres il va avoir deux
titres retard kalichman et house en
janvier leur 22e champion du monde qui a
bon dos mais en face on décemment
anatoli karpov ne peut plus dire qu'il
est champion du monde final il ne l'est
plus il n'ya plus le niveau pour l'être
puisqu'il est 10e mondiale en tout cas
stéphane revenons sur ce championnat du
monde fidesz est un événement puisque il
y à 100 joueurs pratiquement tous sont
là et c'est un système à élimination
directe alors je pense qu'on peut
revenir peut-être là-dessus
oui alors si les mines essonne direct
s'est instituée par le président actuel
de la fédération il nomine off qui a
décidé d'ouvrir un peu ce championnat
demande c'est la troisième édition qui
va avoir lieu sur ce modèle la première
avait eu lieu pays bas avec une finale
en suisse à lausanne
le deuxième a eu lieu à las vegas donc
la première c'est karpov qu'elle a gagné
m'étais qualifié directement finale 2e
kalichman à la surprise générale on va
dire c'était la grosse polémique depuis
un an c'est ça qui se passe un califat
le champion du monde qui est 30e joueur
mondial et qui avait quand même fait un
fantastique tournoi est cette année très
ouverts quoi alors cette année qu'est ce
qui va se passer
kalif manne pour l'instant et le
champion sortant et on voit qu'il a un
début de tableau extrêmement difficile
on va peut-être vous détailler un peu ce
tableau kalichman effectivement c'est le
sujet du jour puisque la partie que nous
allons commenter est une des siennes
donc où il a battu j'ai dit mon lien ou
c'est à dire qu'en l'absence pour
l'instant deux parties a commenté on va
commenter la partie une des dernières
parties du champion du monde en titre
qui va défendre son titre en fait
simplement à noter quand même que parmi
les absents densité karpov et kasparov
chronique il ya aussi une absence on
aurait bien aimé voir si judit polgar
c'est une absence si une absente alors
bon pas qualifiées par le vélo parce
qu'elle est 30e mondial où trouver une
scène où un peu de choses en fait ça se
joue à très peu de choses on sait si
c'est un peu bizarre et pas qualifier
parce qu'elle n'a pas joué les tournois
zonaux pensant peut-être qu'elle allait
y être invités puisque des invités et
non les pas là et on peut se demander
pourquoi les palois que d'autres invités
demande
oui alors effectivement il ya beaucoup
d'eau est qualifié d'office on va dire
par exemple tous les jeunes juniors qui
ont plus de 2600 points elo donc c'est
le cas d'étienne macro qui pour notre
plus grand plaisir
va participer à ce championnat et le
porno mario également ponomariov et je
crois que le dernier segal qui nourrit
tout que je ne m
un petit trou de mémoire ici il ya
également les invités du président il ya
par exemple boris spassky qui a été
invité on ne participe pas pour espace
qui est champion du monde en 69 kg a
décliné l'offre qui a décliné l'offre
il ya quelques invités comme ça on sait
pas trop pourquoi en tout cas une invite
pas la meilleure féminine et c'est bien
dommage tu sais bien dommage mais bon
grosso modo on peut dire que les
meilleurs sont là à l'exception des deux
premiers mondiaux kasparov et crâne il
annoncera la chine offre à la adams
aussi ivantchouk jean marc aillet fois
on est vite on va y revenir sur les
têtes de série plus tard alors stefania
son joueur ce qui nous fait donc un
total de 99 matchs oui effectivement 99
matches on a joué dans ce tournoi et
pour faire jouer sans joueurs eh bien on
fait un système un peu bizarre c'est à
dire qu'on en fait joué au début 72 qui
donne trente six qualifiés auxquels on
rajoute les 28 qui n'ont pas joué sa non
qualifiés d'office
voilà ce qui donne à la fin 64 et là on
commence le système élimination directe
voilà salaires donc premier tour il ya
vingt-huit qualifie d'office donc 72
jours aux joueurs comme tu me dire
qu'ils se qualifient et au deuxième tour
on rentre tout le monde joue tout le
temps et 64 32 16 8 4 2 et 1 1 alors
effectivement pour cette finale et bien
il y aura un déplacement puisque la
première partie se joue on l'a pas
forcément dit à new delhi et la deuxième
partie de la finale le match en six
parties donc se jouera à t on alors à
noter que la finale se joue en plein
noël oui oui alors ça c'est sympa ça se
termine le 27
voilà c'est pas grave
j'étais une histoire spéciale puisque
nous serons là oui donc c'est bien et
nous vous offrons un compte rendu sur
cette finale le mercredi 27 au soir
voilà c'est à dire si vous avez reçu ou
si les amis à vous reçoivent une
connexion internet à noël un parent
modem adsl puisque l'adsl variés et bien
là pour en profiter
ils pourront étrenner leurs cadeaux de
noël éventuel mois là avec le 27 les
missions spéciales des gones à halle
pour fêter entre guillemets à la fois
noël le nouvel an est le nouveau
champion du monde
ça m'étonne des deux alliés je pense
qu'ils auront un gâteau rien dire en un
gâteau exceptionnel donc alors
effectivement c'est des matches en deux
parties c'est à dire s'il ya un gagnant
celui d'une partie nul est bien celui
qui a marqué un point et demi est
qualifié l'autre est éliminé voilà en
cas d'égalité un partout et bien c'est
plus de la même chose il ya des matchs
de semi rapides ses fans en cadence
fischer voilà qui se jouent le lendemain
exactement match semi rapides et s'il ya
des égalités en bout des semi rapide
mais on continue à jouer jusqu'à 1,20
coeur et on réduit la cadence
voilà tout à fait ça va de plus en plus
vite on fait des 25 minutes au départ ou
des vingt minutes + 10 secondes c'est
incrémenté ensuite on finit en blitz
tout simplement cinq minutes par joueur
et là c'est des places qui va le cher
parce qu'on n'a pas encore détaillé les
prix de ce tournoi il ya trois millions
et demi de dollars
en tout ce qui est considérable et
effectivement chaque fois qu'on passe un
tour aux multiples ils sont pris à peu
près par deux moines pas mal
effectivement sur un beat ça peut
conserver leur cher sachant que au
premier tour sont éliminés on gagne
quand même 50 microns alors est-ce que
c'est quand la dernière fois où les prix
étaient pro raté je crois que si je
faisais deux parties nulles il fallait
se départager en partie rapide mais
qu'on gagne on perd des moins d'argent
ce n'est éliminé voyais alors
effectivement c'est c'est possible
qu'ils aient adopté cette ce système
d'assurance comme on appelle ça ouais
bon en tout cas ce n'est pas le souci
principal c'est pas le souci qu'il faut
voir c'est quand même qu'il ya des très
beaux matches donc il ya des têtes de
série alors à noter ce qu on a douté
dans le tableau puisqu'on a le tableau
sous les yeux
on vous invite à visiter le site
officiel on va quand même faire la
publicité du site officiel c'est normal
c'est le world fi des points comme le
site de la file et oui c'est le voile
fidèles qui vous renverra sur un autre
site jumeau qui est dédié à ce
championnat du monde
voilà donc vous allez sur fi des points
comme ou world fi des points comme les
deux marches et ensuite vous avez le
lien direct vers cette grille de tournoi
vers tout un tas de choses
voilà donc site officiel évidemment de
la fédération alors à noter qu'il ya une
partie du tableau qui est extrêmement
relevée lois tuent à noter que
extrêmement relevé il s'agit du deuxième
8e de tableau ouais et bien dans ce donc
on retrouve évidemment en tête de série
peter l'écho et nigel short dans ce
fameux huitième de tableau mais il y a
également qualifié
bref c'est une surprise est-ce que ça
fait a priori quand même trois têtes de
série
c'est ce qu'il est énorme et cali
semaine peu rencontré l'écho c'est ça
voilà quelques semaines pour rencontrer
les co au troisième tour au troisième
tour est à noter que l'écho a écrasé
kalichman 1 janvier dernier par quatre
victoires en 3 victoires à 0 voire 3
victoires à 0 en 6 parties donc ils
avaient vraiment proprement exécuté
quelques semaines c'était un peu vengé
je crois puisqu'il avait gagné il avait
gagné une partie à linares oui contre
les gros mais a priori gros avantage
l'écho et d'un ce même tableau on va
retrouver lautier qui s'y passe et les
deux tours va rencontrer short et ces
joueurs là le genre d'attention stéphane
qui ont enterré quand même notre
français gorna ta wii qui jouera short
s'il bat suite au ski au premier tour
cette optique un israélien à sa portée
clairement ligue en attaque peut gagner
ce premier tour alors qu'il est bon il
est quand même outsider mais à ce moment
là j'aurais short au deuxième tour et là
effectivement grosse partie à noter que
si joël et igor gagnent ils se
rencontreront en troisième tour ouais
ben là encore français donc il ne
pourrait y en avoir plus qu'un il y en
aurait plus qu'un et ea lorsque bacrot
lui est ce qu'il est la meilleure un
tableau alors bacrot où est il il joue
au premier tour ichanov oui pas facile
et s'il passe je crois qu'il joue contre
peeters fidelaire si je n'ai pas dit oui
je crois
et ça c'est très très dur parce que
spider a battu plusieurs fois garry
kasparov
donc il est extrêmement fort peeters
fille de l'air à noter qu'il ya quand
même un autre c'était fans un autre
français d'adoption c'est vladislav
tkachiev qui lui un début de tableau
assez facile oui katy se qualifier les
premiers tours voilà il est qualifié
d'office au premier sens que ça c'est
important
et au deuxième tour il jouera le
vainqueur du match le siège vasquez
parce qu'à ce qu'est le joueur chilien
le siège québécois effectivement il a
toutes ses chances à ce deuxième tour et
après il affrontera une tête de série
qui n'en est pas une il s'agit de kazim
janov qu'il ya un classement à mon avis
un peu sur surévalué et donc qu'on voit
bien vladislav tkachiev se retrouver
contre morozevich au troisième tour ce
qui serait un très très bon match
puisque dans un vide chez évidemment
c'est office de favorite alors on nous
on a fait un tableau idéal
le vainqueur supposer ses vives à la tan
anand à noter qu'un fait attendait son
prénom et j'ai lu ça sur un site indien
on se trompe tous en europe on appelle
viswanathan anand est en fait un an que
c'est son prénom il ya que sa femme qui
l'appelle comme ça qu'ils appellent un
harnais en fait il appelle par son
prénom et sévices manhattan son nom mais
bon nous on avait l'habitude de
considérer l inverse on feb en attendant
final un an de gagne le tournoi clos
stéphane puisque en finale ils
affronteraient donc a priori cheer of
voilà non c'est bon on évite schickel
deuxième place n'est autre que je n'ai
pas de d'énormités mais c'est moins
évident qu'à deuxième classement très
surprenant j'ai été très surpris de voir
ça sur le site de la fidh et donc je
tiens cette source officielle ouais mais
c'est là c'est la mise à jour 2 le duel
au mois mois après mois peut-être c'est
ça peut-être en tout cas toujours est il
que morose et nietzsche et conseillère
et tête de série numéro 2 mais ils
affronteraient donc à nantes en finale
n'aura évidemment pas pour ça c'est sous
sas et voilà qu'il en avait vu à las
vegas que les têtes de série tombent
comme des fruits mûrs ce que je crois
que pour les demi finales il y avait
trois autres cider complet il s'agissait
de nice ip à nous akopian est le dernier
qualifié kalichman sans vie de ces gars
que adams qui était arrivé non c'était
adams stéphane il s'agissait si c'était
adamski et qui avait perdu contre
akopian ah oui oui oui tout à fait je
m'en rappelle très bien dans cette
arrivée en demi finale ce qui veut dire
que les têtes de séries vont arriver
quand même assez loin a priori adams est
très fort en match c'est vrai que
l'effort il était déjà en finale du
précédent championnat du monde trois
contre un angle exactement alors le plus
impressionnant c'est quand même
évidemment mishna lannan ondes qui n'a
joué qu'une seule fois en hollande
et il est arrivé en fait vainqueur de
l'épreuve sauf que quand on avait gagné
quand on a gagné ce système à
élimination directe et bien il y avait
karpov qui arrivait tout frais ouais et
qui en six parties deux jours après
effectivement à nantes qui revient de un
mois de folie de sueurs froides stupeur
à la fin ça s'est joué dans les blitz
contre michael adams en finale et
ensuite deux jours après il faut jouer
karpov qui arrive en ayant regardé le
tournoi de loin puisqu'il n'y a pas
participé et donc il s'est incliné
contre kharkov
voilà alors suivi de ce championnat du
monde est bien tour après tour avec des
invités très intéressant on va on va en
parler tout de suite alors à partir de
lundi donc c'est ça appartient c'est à
partir de mercredi stars dont il de
mercredi la 3e 29 sites un peu mercredi
la neuve et en gros tous les trois jours
un tous les trois jours oui puisqu'il
n'ya pas deux jours de repos il n'y a
pas de jour entre deux parties puissent
les semi rapide de partie si on gagne
les deux parties en un jour de repos
mais si on gagne pas il faut jouer les
semi rapides et nous le soir en fait un
compte-rendu vieux la journée avec les
qualifiés qui les têtes de série qui
sont tombés analyse des plus belles
parties je pense qu'on va dire ça un
avis des plus belles positions voire
d'une partie entière si elle est aussi
très intéressante analyse du tour
suivant et ce à tous les trois jours
jusqu'au 27
à noter qu'à partir des demi-finales ou
des car je sais plus dense et les
demi-finales qui se joue en quatre
parties les deux finales se jouent en 4
parties donc là ça sera au bout de cinq
jours et la finale se joue ainsi partie
est à noter qu'il ya quand même un petit
m'enfin ça on vous préviendra en cours
de route de toute façon voilà donc notre
premier invité ce sera jean claude main
qui viendra mercredi 29 puisqu'il ya
deux clichois et que jean claude et
président du club de clichy ixe nataf et
de ce club et je vais lautier également
donc il ne pourra nous parler un peu de
leur préparation et ainsi de suite nous
éclairera sur ce début de championnat
donc et puis on va voir si l'hôte il est
passé il ya un staff aussi c'est ça
intéressant elle dit
donc là jean-claude il va peut-être
arriver soit très heureux soit à moitié
heureux et soit pas heureux du tout on
va en faire bien et alors on aura aussi
laurent frayssinet il y aura l'une
bergez qui va nous rejoindre
non je déconne et olivier rhône et pour
la première fois je crois que vous voyez
sur diagonale mars un taureau manquez
déjà venu quand même beaucoup aller à
bonal 3 fois champion de france qui
viennent autoroute exprès et ça je suis
content pour autant commenter ces tours
etc ce championnat du monde et je crois
que norman robert fontaine aussi
maubert-fontaine fabrègues tout un tas
de personnalités qui viendront nous
aider leur antre signer on l'a oublié
non je lui dit de faire avec les offres
à signer quand même très indépendante
être harmoush a peut-être un auchan
voilà donc vrai sur beaucoup de maîtres
et grands maîtres français qui viendront
nous éclairer nous donner leur avis sur
ce championnat sur les tours qui passe
et ça sera très intéressant alors
stéphane peut-être qu'on va garder une
partie du champion en titre alors on va
regarder maintenant pour se mettre la
bouche l'eau à la bouche un petit peu
c'est d'une titre d'ailleurs d'une
émission une autre émission de canal web
lé que je vous invite à découvrir l'eau
à la bouche avec la partie kalichman
contre judit polgar alors pourquoi parce
que kalichman et le champion du monde en
titre et que aaa alors là haut
laissez sécher très surprenant on a à
peu près ça alors je continue pendant
que oui peut-être en plein écran
d'ailleurs oui donc là voilà un petit on
a une petite saute de machines
voilà alors je suis pas que tu peux
l'être oui alors je pense comprendre que
tu as un mot de passe ce qui est
important voilà nous nous sommes à leurs
revenus
finalement sur 7 sur cette superbe
partie de californie en plus ça marche
donc ça c'est ça c'est bien donc quel
fan contre judit polgar a noté stéphane
que kalichman est très très chaud c'est
un tournoi qui s'est jouée à essent
hollande
ouais et kalichman a fait le score
absolument incroyable de cinq et demi
sur six faisons une performance à plus
de 3000 points bros wii et donc ça veut
dire pour autant qu'on a bien fait je
pense devoir kalichman c'est quand même
le champion du monde en titre même s'il
a surpris l'année dernière et bien il
sera sûrement très dangereux encore
cette année il a été assez bon
finalement les invitations qui l'a fait
cette année dans le tournoi semble t'il
ça encore élever son niveau de jeu et en
ce dernier tombe nez à nez démontre que
il était il est encore très fort et
qu'il faudra compter avec lui oui tout à
fait alors il avait un style extrêmement
pur il aller jusqu'au bout dans ces
parties jusqu'au bout de ses plans et
ses idées et là c'est ce qu'on va voir
une partie qu'on peut qualifier de
partis modèle stéphane contre j'ai dit
polga voilà alors allons-y on va voir
l'échiquier
voilà voilà donc quelques images ou des
quatre cavaliers f6 c4 aussi ce donc là
évidemment c'est une proposition de
ninkovic s'il est blanc choqué et c3 les
noirs que je fous b4 et clouer le
cavalier kalichman décline gentiment
cette proposition en jouant qu'avec des
f3 qui est un coût plus positionnelle a
priori plus tranquille beaucoup
d'attentes presque 1 pour savoir ce
qu'on va faire les noirs n'ont alors non
stéphane est effectivement des
ouvertures il faut sortir ses pièces au
plus vite
c'est ce qu'on fait c'est un coût de
développement le plan c'est de jouer
soit eu deux trois suites sortir le
fouet petit rock soit g2 g3 sortir le
fouet petit rock on veut
ok rapidement dans cette partie ces 5
alors ça c'est un coup violent moins
violent un peu d'un style de judith un
jeu dit elle aime bien tout ce qui est
compliqué il est parti bien compliqué
bien tactique donc qu'elle met le feu à
l'échiquier tout de suite contre attaque
au centre plastique classique c'est une
contre attaque au centre la menace
immédiate des noirs c'est simplement de
jouer ces 5 38 ans des quatre et on
rentre dans une presque une sicilienne
dans un pré alors ça dépend ce que je
voulais blanc n'est pas ce que je lui
avais pas tout à fait c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça donc la menace est
chaude surprend des caps tout simplement
échanger le pion c'est contre l'option
des blancs ça c'est important pourquoi
parce qu'après on se retrouve avec deux
pions contrairement au centre il y en
aura deux ici et des verts n'auront plus
qu'un ouais donc ça c'est un avantage
sur le long terme
d'autant plus que les noirs sont leurs
pièces très facilement après avec ses 6
le fou qui sort et petit rock
donc ça c'est très passionnel évidemment
les blancs eux jouent d4 d5 évite de
donner le centre tout de suite ça c'est
très normal
et là on arrive dans une sorte de
comment s'appelle ce débat de benoni
c'est une belle au niveau là âgées le
môme était sorti sorti de la tête en
achète pas je connais pas bien ce type
d'ouverture mais ça ressemble
effectivement à benoni lors des 5 alors
des six décision n'empêche on empêche
les blindes jouer des six semaines
cédant alors les marins ne peuvent pas
jouer dès 6 ans en règle générale on ne
peut pas conserver des pions là bas
alors pourquoi je bats parce qu'il va
falloir le jouer tout simplement
c'est un coup que quand vous êtes amené
à jouer ça contrôler la catho cinq mois
mais ça aussi on pouvait pas jouer fois
aux sept puisque où il a effectivement
blanc tous leurs pions attaquant fou et
on gagne un temps alors stéphane on va
ça c'est encore ma place et histoire de
bien comprendre ce qui est en train de
se passer dans cette partie oui les
blancs ici ont envie de jouer le pion eu
deux ans le 4 c'est sûr pour pouvoir
blindés justement cette caste des cinq
donc il joue key c3 dans un premier
temps normal développe les pièces là et
menaçe jouer aux quatre voilà les noirs
prennent en d5 et blanc reprennent et
ici un coût qui est assez intéressant
recommandé par la théorie c'est le
ku'damm hausse est pour justement éviter
à ceux de gravité 2/4 pourquoi pas damas
7 c'est possible mais je n'ai pas le
gars joue g6 là on est vraiment dans la
baie noni pourquoi oui parce qu'on va
mettre le fond angers7
il verra une belle diagonale parce que
ils profitent de fait du fait que les
pions noirs son show cases noires qui
protège déjà bien les cases noires au
centre et le fou va rajouter de la
pression
voilà sur la diagonale tout à fait alors
les plans sont très simples de toute
façon la position se développe
naturellement ici les blancs prennent le
centre
et je veux que 2,4 fou g7 et maintenant
qu'est ce qu'on va voir et bien les
noirs tout simplement ils veulent jouer
avec leurs pions qui sont là ouais et y
en a 7 et bessat qui veulent les
avancées c'est quand on a dire il faut
dire belle poussée influent bekkat c'est
une bonne opération pour les noirs
puisque ça rallonge encore l'efficacité
du fou gesac les blancs eux ils ont un
plan c'est de jouer aux 4/5 faire valoir
leur majorité centrale puisqu'il en
d'options contre un seul donc voilà les
plans de cette position et honnêtement
j'ai un gros problème stéphane puisque
chaque fois que avec les blanches puis
ils confrontés à cette benoni et bien je
ne sais plus quoi faire donc je ne suis
pas un expert en benoni ouais mais ici
quelques semaines joue le coup 8 h 3
alors l'idée c'est simple on l'a déjà
dit dans diagonale là je vous invite
c'est un principe général donc je vous
invite à bien y faire attention quand
notre adversaire a fait un flop ghetto
il a mis ses pions comme ça avec le fou
à l'intérieur et bien le fou de l'autre
côté il faut absolument éviter qu'ils ne
les changeons donc c'est l'idée de ce
coup h3c pour empêcher que le foot vient
d'angers 4 s'échanger des femmes contre
le cavaliere 3 way alors pourquoi ça et
bien parce que là on voit justement que
le fou les cases où il avait envie
d'aller cd case verte
là où il ya les pions noirs il pourra
donc pas y aller donc se trouve être une
charge pour le développement des lois
ils ne savent pas où m voilà pourquoi ce
petit coup h2 h3 qui est très important
et qui doit être jouée le plus vite
possible les noirs jean petit rock ouï
fou sur la case d3 donc normal
développement on tient un pur 4 on le
renforce à 7 à 6
donc là on aurait visiblement les noirs
peuvent menacer des jouets 17 b 5 avec
une expansion elle dame tout à fait b5
suivi éventuellement soin de ses quatre
soit de b4 ça serait très souple il faut
pas donner au noir cette chance donc on
joue à deux à quatre noms des cinq soirs
de questions voilà ai-je dit le lire ces
nouveautés
alors c'est une nouveauté c'est une
nouveauté dames c'est cette non alors
j'ai vérifié j'ai vérifié dans la base
j'ai pas trouvé deux parties avec ce
coup dams et 7 qui est stéphane très
curieux on est très curieux mais je
compte lui dit il ya beaucoup de joueurs
qui disent que des fois jouent des
couturiers oui notamment peter l'écho
qui nous avait dit ça
ils ne comprennent ils comprenaient pas
toujours les coups de judy qu elle a des
idées et bien à elle quoi voyez vous
avez tout à fait alors c'est un coup et
effectivement on n'en comprend pas très
bien le sens sartre ans pose ensuite
dans quelque chose de connu
en tout cas l'idée c'est de pouvoir
développer ceux qui habitent en 17 cents
ça fait bien l'option des six serpents
remarque si on se met dans la position
précédente
si on voulait sortir le cavaliere 17 et
bien le tour des six se retrouver sans
défense mais pas attaquer pour même s'il
n'est pas attaqué et bien je dis décide
de jouer aux dames c'est cette c'est pas
grave puisque ça revient dans quelque
chose d'assez connu un petit rock qui
avait 17 maintenant car il est 17 tours
on les blancs restent dans leurs plans
ça paraît assez logique donc l'un pour
préparer la poussée ils veulent tôt ou
tard poussé aux cinq avec un échange du
pinot noir et on aurait pu s'en passer
pour les blanches voilà et bien c'est le
thème de cette partie stéphane c'est le
fameux pions dépasser très important
toro vite joué par les noirs là on est
dans une position assez classique a noté
stéphane que les blancs ont une faute
positionnelle à ne pas jouer dans cette
position c'est le coût à 5
oui alors il y en a beaucoup qui se
disent je peux jouer à 5 donc c'est bien
pourquoi
et bien parce qu'une fois que je voulais
jouer si on fait des 5 on peut prendre
un v6 le passé récent ouais et la
structure noir se retrouve affaibli
besoin on imagine sans cette option là
ouais eh bien on voit qu'il ya deux
pions le pion à six qui est isolée tout
faire pour quoi c'est pas bien et alors
en fait positionnement c'est à bien
simplement on peut regarder on va
envisager cette possibilité
ouais si les points chauds à 5 il y
aurait des cinq quand même quand même et
à champions prend hélas on reprendrait
soit de la dame soit du cavalier en fait
ça n'a pas une grosse importance je
pense préfère préférence pour la dame
oui
et maintenant on voit que les noirs ont
ouvert la colonne des dons qui zonent
colin est chargé pions b2 ouais cercle
plan b 2 se retrouve quasiment aussi
faible que le pion à 6 voire même plus
faibles voilà tout à fait et en plus ils
vont mettre la tour sur la case b8
mouais donc ils vont réussir finalement
à activer toutes leurs pièces très
facilement donc ça ce n'est pas
conseillé ne faut pas jouer à simple
parce que pour l'instant des cinq n'est
pas une menace
et même si on affaiblit la structure
sont affaiblis plus raciste et bien ce
n'est pas important du tout l'activité
des pièces noires sera trop forte donc
c'est à éviter absolument ne jouais pas
à cinq danseurs de police voilà faut
être quatre bientôt être pas mal donc ça
met la pression sur des
his ça justifie le coup de judith dams
et 7 qui protège ses pions est bon par
contre ça rajoute de la pression sur la
case ou 5 avec 4,5 qui deviennent de
plus en plus probable judith joue tourbe
et vite
alors cette fois ci ça semble pouvoir
menacer les baies 5 me enfin ce n'est
pas encore trop grave il n'y a pas de
problème pour l'instant fous ces quatre
ça c'est plutôt bien joué de la part de
qualif man c'est bizarre quand même
parce qu'une orientation que ça
n'empêche pas une world un v6 on ne peut
pas jouer des 5 9 et 5 s'est emplie
s'est défendu trois fois pour l'instant
ouais alors que les noirs dans le
contrôle que deux fois donc ça c'est pas
possible
quelle est l'idée de secours ou c4 si on
regarde cette position le fou et en d3
mais on voulait pas le même temps des
trois ans stéphane parce que on l'a mis
là juste pour défendre une carte c'était
temporaire donc maintenant que le pian 4
et défendre la marque sur une case plus
forte
voilà on sait car il est très fort il
est fort pourquoi parce que alors là
stéphane à l'explication est très simple
quand on joue e5 way est bien le fou c4
se retrouvent braqués vers le roi il ya
des perspectives de jaude et 6,6 à la
dame derrière qui vient soutenir le pion
oui bref ça commence à faire énormément
de facteurs en faveur du français qui
peut se réveiller quoi c'est un
potentiel de réveil
voilà le pion des cinq thibault qui
bouge pardon pour l'instant ce fou et
amené plus tard à devenir mobile une
fois qu'on aura joué de 4,5 en plus donc
on a dégagé cette colonne des ça c'est
important dans tout un tas de variantes
ici qu'elle avait six coups surprenant
de la part de judith oui parce qu'avoir
le cavalier on a l'impression qu'ils
terminent mal placé parce qu'il est
devant le pion b donc là le coup tomber
8 semble
du coup
ne plus avoir d'intérêt et il est
ce qui ne va pas ou il peut aller alors
c'est effectivement ce n'est pas en
harmonie avec le plan quand on quand on
a joué tour b 8 on n'a pas du tout envie
de choquer et b6 et après il mais que
pouvait faire judit polgar dans cette
position peut-être pas valable dans
cette position-là à parquet et b6 on ne
sait pas trop comment faire
il ya un flan normalement qui consiste à
jouer éventuellement cavaliers h 58 cas
vidéo 5
elle a dû l'envisager je sais pas
pourquoi la page où elle a préféré les
idées si ce qui n'est pas un coup
positionnelle sur quoi évidemment
quelques semaines revient en f1
ouais pas de problème moi étaient
désorganisés mais moi je n'ai pas de
problème donc je vous ai pas mal en f1
et ça laisse le noir avec mon club et si
ce qui sert pas à grand chose mais si je
vous dit revenez que peut-être on
pouvait revenir si j'ai dit revenez je
ne pense pas que
et kalichman serait revenu il aurait
pendant que améliorer ses pièces il
encore des coûts moyens il peut jouer
tour c1 qu'ils ont peut-être dam des
deux pour les échanges et les fous avec
franchise peut-être c'est une
possibilité mais je lui dis tu avais un
plan quand même elle joue cavalier f17
alors l'idée pourquoi et bien avoir
changé les cavaliers de place puisque
avant on peut considérer que calais b si
c'était sur l'exercice bien simplement
ça dégage et le fou g7
ouais ça va maintenant se fout et
dégager les caisses de sein qui est très
bien contrôlés voilà ça c'est important
donc les noirs contrôle mais cette case
de 5 peut-être les noirs aussi un plan
de jouer ces cinq c4 c'est possible ça
c'est 500 son cavalier sur la case ccnq
peut-être ça c'est ça son visage a noté
stéphane que dans cette pression ce
jeudi de jouer avec le feu puisque
quelques semaines quand il veut peut
jouer à 4 à 5
ouais qui forcera le club et si saleh
sur l'a15 habite à ou ne serait pas du
tout actif mais les noirs pourrait quand
même se libérer les ressortir être
trawick effectivement donc pour
l'instant c'est pas grave je pense que
le plan noir dans cette position serait
d'échanger des pions au plus vite
échanger des pièces pour pouvoir un peu
sortir de cet étau respirer un peu quoi
voilà ici qualif lanzhou 16 torcéen a
noté à ce fou 6,8 des noirs qui a pas de
case se fout c'est huit toutes les cases
blanches sont contrôlés par le pion
alors il y aurait que la case 17 mai
pour l'instant les indispensables pour
les noirs puisque les cavaliers
transitent par cette case cavaliers en
bo5
ça y est c'est l'heure des changes et
des pièces aussi vite que possible et la
qualif ne trouve une superbe
transformation assez inattendu je dois
dire je pense pas que ça soit hippiques
enfin cette position-là est complexe il
joue qu'à l'aller prend cavaliers way
fou prend quasiment forcé il prend
encore elle prend encore curieux 1 c'est
curieux et la judith si elle avait pris
de la tour si elle prendre la tour
probablement les blancs jouent le coup à
f2 f4 voilà c'est ça alors c'est le gros
problème judith a pris du plomb on voit
envisagé ce qui se serait passé surtout
reprend et bien il y aurait le coup f2f
4 effectivement ces femmes et 1 tour 8
tours 8
et là je crois que c'est leur 2e 5
peut-être peut-être le simple idée alors
ses clics et ses 3 il arrive en 4 mois
ensuite ils menacent de sa wii exercice
que là les cases noires sont très
faibles bien ta culture décimerait ses
terres il sait traduire on est plus ou
moins virtuellement obligé de prendre
voilà est là pour battre le mans mesure
possibilité cinq des six salariés hors
d'ici ce qui est pas mal colère fois
suis simplement la reprise en 5
et on voit que la casa fils ne pourra
plus être défendu après cavaliers aux
quatre c'est la catastrophe toutes les
pièces de qualif en sont bien passées va
se réveiller
ouais le second csn y deviennent fiables
aussi bon si nous attirons en défense
bref une catastrophe donc ici après
français judit polgar est obligé de
reprendre du pillon et là tu as passé
pour les blancs
j'en passe et protéger ces femmes
protège les plus grands il est protégé
par le pion aux 4 et il n'est pas
bloquée et il n'est pas bloqué ces
terres que là il ya un autre problème
donc tu en province et à quelques toiles
de jouer il joue un coup subtil toi
subtil le koundan d2 tranquille fait une
menace fait une menace alors ça se voit
pas ça se voit pas tout de suite ça soit
pas tout de suite la monarchie est créée
par ce coup des deux non je ne vois pas
là alors on peut ce oui effectivement
c'est on peut se demander pourquoi
eh bien j'ai dit tu n'as pas joué le
ku'damm des six mois est par exemple
l'un des six qui semble pas mal dans la
mesure où ça bloque l'option assez
embêtant de notre rupture avec une dame
leila une combinaison stéphane caine
compte dès le coup à 4 à 5 à chasse le
cavalier lecavalier vient vraisemblement
sur la case 17 - et maintenant après
cavaliers à 4 eh bien il ya plus de
coûts pour les noirs ja oui les dires
des autres ou les noirs sont quasiment
vie c'est tout simplement plus de coups
dans cette position on ne peut plus rien
faire si on essaie de jouer des 5
la réaction logique à rejouer ouais y
lire tu en prends tu comprend ainsi qu'à
va les prendre car l'option c'est un art
si on prend la tour évidemment perry
qualité ouais il faut prendre du
cavalier up en premier chevalier hélas
hélas cavalli procurent ces cinq c'est
terminé tout simplement gagner monsieur
en avait toujours une position très
forte donc vais rendre sympathique par
ce coup simple dames des deux dans cette
position nous remontre ouais il a joué
d'amd d'eau et bien il crée la menace à
5 puis qu'il va dire à 4 et 8 passes et
la dame des deux protégerait à ce moment
là c'est ça c'est lapointe dame protège
la casa c est à dire que même si khalifa
ne joue pas d'amd si ce n'est un autre
coup cette menace est quand même
d'actualité
par exemple sur food et 7 peut dire fou
décède suite cavaliers s'est vite calmé
la scène gagne le pion csn tout à fait
donc d'un des deux coups subtil n'en
revenant pas ce que sont fous 17 ans
peut pas lutter il ya quatre loin oui
oui effectivement rien il faudrait que
je reconsidère la question mais
peut-être surtout 17
il ya d'autres variantes
abbas deux des six peut-être non là je
ne sais pas ses propos brice et prononça
je suis pas ce que c'est que 17 des six
on peut jouer car il y décèle ensuite
peut-être sera près 1,5 je suis pas les
choses comme ça à voir en tout cas la
menace c'est à 5 et cavaliers à 4 voilà
non food et 7 n'a pas été joué à la
chaux et qu'elle les effets du dit oui
mais la qualité est vraiment il a très
très bien joué cette partie des cinq des
six c'est l'heure maintenant les noirs
menacé de bloquer le pion il faut pas
les laisser bloquer damas 5 c'est
logique ça cloue lequel et ses 3 ouest
de calais bouger ni besoin d'agir et
vient dans le dessein que la dame ait
perdu important elle tout à fait puisque
effectivement la dame s'arrêter alors
tour d un tour d eux ils comptent et
augmente la pression sur le pion des on
fait supporter le pion dès maintenant la
dame n'est plus en prison peut peut-être
aussi jouer cavalier le cavaly peu bougé
il ya une chose que fait kalichman
extrêmement bien vous avez pu le voir
dans tous les coups qu'il a joués chaque
fois qu'il ya un casque est pas en jeu
eh bien ils l'armée dans l'action c'est
ce qu'il vient de faire avec ce coup
tours 20 en d1 la tour on avait plus
rien à faire sur la colonne way et
l'armée sur la colonne des voiles a très
bien joué roger c'est ça c'est logique
on avait très peur des invasions du
cavalier qui moi la meilleure fiche est
avec toi là y'a plus d'échecs fide et
sont maintenant autre grand principe
khalifa n'a envie de mettre son pied sur
la caisse des 5
pour l'instant il peut pas souvent à
améliorer nos charges de dames ya le
pion à quatre reprises il ya les changes
de dan donc ça fait deux bonnes raisons
qui l'empêchent de jouer qui a aidé 5 no
qu'il joue d'abord dang tran il se
décline parce qu'il n'a pas envie de les
changer d'âme pourquoi le roi que j'ai
dite est plus faible que le sien on voit
que leur argent est très bien défendu
alors que le roi l'est beaucoup moins
deux cases noires sont faibles
effectivement grands principes quand le
roi de votre adversaire faible et bien
donné changeait pas les dames c'est très
sain c'est très simple c'est très clair
des six maintenant alors toujours pareil
sur qui est des cinq judith trouverait
du contre jeu en prenant le curé 4 donc
des 3b 3 protège les pions 1,4
tranquille tu as joué des coups simples
la canssm années faciles à comprendre
oui je vous écouterai simple pourquoi
elle vient parce qu'il a un énorme
avantage c'est ce pion décision des six
qui n'est pas attaqué qui est très très
énervant pour les noirs mais tu vois pas
comment les noirs peut le prendre parce
que
il est sûr qu'à ce noir donc le fou de
cases blanches ne peut pas l'attaquer le
cavalier doit rester où il est pour le
bloquer reste que les tours et la dame
mais on va pas c'est pas possible effet
aston n'y a pas de colonne pour
l'attaqué kalichman est en train de
remettre ces pièces en jeu et il est un
objectif très simple ça c'est ce qu'on
va voir
après c'est à dire que le pion des six
va jouer le rôle d'une diversion ça
c'est bien vu fouler cette foule
bessette fous ces quatre donc là il
réactive son fou à la date qui jouait
pas reste maintenant peut-être la course
est longue et qu'il a à l'air de pas
trop jouer la wii alors mais la tour
s'était fait ne peut toujours travailler
dans la mesure où le plan des noirs
c'est comme de jouer des 5 6 1 ce cas là
c'est le seul plan puisqu'ils ont 38 ans
contre 2 ouais donc ils ont envie
d'avancer celui-là de m de lemaitre en
bessin qui c'est logique
hélas la tour s'élance le révélera et
sera un très bon défenseur fous ces six
joué par judith norman est maintenant
food et cinq bien joué aussi
oui parce qu'en fait sur le fou noir la
limite est plus actif que le football un
oui et il ya aussi un autre facteur
c'est qu'il a envie de mettre son
cabinet en décembre qu'il ya un vide m
il veut pas qu'on les change son
cavalier donc là il échange des
fougasses blanche et après il va aller
en des cinq étoiles à son cahier sera
beaucoup plus fort que son homologue
noir tourbe et s'évitent pointe pourquoi
et bien si on joue au foot rend fou mais
qui est possible voilà après tout
reprendre leur été dans l'idée tout
reprend les cahiers des cinq est pas
possible puisque on perdrait le pion des
s'initier des cinq problème
effectivement il ya tout reprend décide
tout simplement et ça ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas acceptable du tout il ne veut
pas alexander friedman dans cette
position pas de fou prend ces sites
voilà pour l'instant c'est une première
une première chose donc là par contre
quelques semaines décide de passer aux
choses sérieuses la cabine alors
pourquoi est ce qu'il décide ça stéphane
parce que toutes ces pièces sont bien
placé il peut pas les améliorer donc là
il est en l île à la recherche de
quelque chose
voilà il se dit qu'est ce qui se passe
je constate que la dame à 5 de judith
est mal placée elle est pas trop dans
l'action elle est vraiment clairement
marquées à gauche de l'échiquier
oui et puis et donc elle protège plus du
tout le roi donc c'est leur jeu joue f4
mettant le feu à l'échiquier
c'est vrai puisqu'il a fait dix huit
même son propre camp oui mais c'est pas
grave il a tapé là voilà il veut il veut
faire sauter les cases noires
du côté du côté noir il veut allumer le
roi donc là je dis tu réagis aussi ça
c'est normal
oui c'est on va on reviendra à la partie
douala c'est bon b 5 puis on prend b5
c'est là oui c'est effectivement une
réaction très logique chronologique
moyens classiques quand on est attaqué
comme çà une réaction c'est toujours
simple oui mais il faut il faut pas se
laisser surprendre 25 sur france 5
il faut pas se laisser déborder par le
jeu des blancs sinon mon sens les repas
et la qualif mhadjou puis on prend 2,5
et comprend 1,5 alors à noter que sur
cavaliers prend il y aurait sûrement une
combinaison il y aurait sans doute une
combinaison stéphane à base du pion qui
avance alors on va le montrer non je
crois qu'il ya en france et 5 tout
simplement alors alors on va voir à
regarder cavaliers pro 5 c'est le coupon
envie de jouer ouais c'est le coup qu'on
a envie de jouer johnny l'anomie à foug
prince et six cas les arts ou dom
français 5 d'un procès ce point c'est si
c'est bien
j'apprends c'est ce dernier qui arrange
en tant que voisin que c'est le plus les
fans ça gagne pain bio et en plus pas
n'importe lequel puisque ceux qui ont
décidé c'est trop fort et ce pion était
la base du contrôle des noirs ouais mais
que les noirs peuvent pas le donner
comme ça wen a produit en preuve c'est
qu'il faut qu'il reprenne avec la tour
c'est ce qu'il a fait j'ai dit oui
jamais très agréable à même d'amener
tous ici non ça c'est sûr c'est pas la
case à ce qu'est ce qu'une trop c'est
trop pour activer de loin mais alors là
la tour est tout près du pillon alors
que de noël et elle n'est pas plus mal
quoi donc en fait c'est jamais bien
d'orage de ramener une tour près du
présomption adverse disons que pour
l'instant la tour est exposé et ça c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle
et en plus elles contrôlent plus les
castes de promotion du pion elle est
très mal placé cette tour d'un f4 alors
de mettre 4 c'est pas mal ça peut
menacer le pion aux sept déjà sept zones
as directement et en plus un oeil sur
l'accroissement alassane est sur scène
le cavaly 17 ne peut plus bouger du tout
déjà qu'il était un peu bloquée donc la
foux prendre des celtes et unsa y est
c'est il est temps il est temps que la
cei normal on est on évite d'en prendre
cet échec
voilà c'était le seul moyen de
l'appareil cavaliers prends ça y est il
est arrivé il est arrivé de cavaliers et
s'échoue il est très très méchante c'est
chaud il est très très loin d'être une
menace peut être une menace mais dans
des blancs c'est de jouer le coup
cavaliers en f6 surprenant mais l'idée
c'est que le cavalier 17 protège la tour
au self c'est vrai ce coup cavani hamsik
yvon ressemble à une menace sérieuse
parce que là sur cavani prendre cavalli
évidemment dame prend tous viennent les
qualités oui et que je voulais noir oui
que de jeunes en sachant combien ce qui
est préoccupant mais dans ce cas les
points qu'elle avait toujours la tour
emprise donc il faut près vous prévenir
cette menace était fan il faut défendre
la qualité cet essai pour ces lacazette
si ce que j'ai dit tout d'un des huit
dames de huit pas mal ça défend le
cavalier protège la case et fils est en
fait pas mal mais je crois stéphane que
à partir de cette position
les noirs sont perdants c'est possible
ouais mais là à dire que la qualif man a
joué tous les coups mieux maintenant et
je n'ai pas trouvé d'alternative pour
judith pour sauver cette partie ouais
mais là c'est dur là c'est dur parce que
là on voit que là malheureusement pour
judith la tour au 5e mal placé et
emprise de la dame le pion c5 est
attaqué
le cavaly d5 est monstrueux et peut
sauter sur les cases eu cette ou ces
sept que d activation désactivation
total de la défense malgré tout à fait
donc c'est pas facile quoi pour les
noirs n'ont plus qu'à les fun à jouer
vraiment les coups de massue
systématiquement il commence par jouer
cavalier hausse est pas mal attac la
tour s'est vite attaque le 3 septembre
n'a pas beaucoup de cassis à tour ne
peuvent aller ni sur la casse et 7 ni
sur la castille 6 elle peut pas aller
non plus sur la classe b 8 puisque là il
y aurait cavaliers en c6 avec une
fourchette
attaquant à la fois la tour et la toro
cents donc grâce une case pour cette
tour une seule case mais stéphane ya un
problème aussi sur tours à huit il y
avait 10 et 6 quand même aider oui mais
c'est la partie n'a pas le choix j'ai
dit tous ravis de cet objet a noté
effectivement que si on perd une qualité
dans cette position-là qualité c'est la
tour contre le cavalier way
et bien c'est complètement perdant
pourquoi et bien parce que les tours
blanches serait trop forte
mais c'est encore une fortune cavalli
c'est ce qu'on va voir tout de suite
puisque la 4e journée 6 et quand même
fourchette puisque cette fois c'est la
dame et l'ocde vite qui est attaquée et
la toro scène qu'il faut bouger la dame
évidemment faut pas laisser la dame en
prisme qui signa un moyen donc là
entraînez vous vous avez le temps de
trouver la solution pour les noirs mais
non un moyen de sauver la qualité alors
général faut faire des contre attaques
il faut faire des contre attaques
exactement sachant qu'il ya deux pièces
attaquer c'est pas évident donc en fait
il faut prendre une pièce d'attaqué et
l'envoyer attaqué quelque chose d'autre
c'est le coût qui joue ici d'objets 5
voilà à quoi la dame pas mal pas mal
et si la dame vient prendre la dame et
la tour prendra voilà la tour par le ser
l'efs de la prise du cavalier en
reprenant tout simplement tout
simplement voilà donc en fait en deux
coups et bien que judith aurait réussi à
évacuer ces deux pièces attaquer mais
d'ailleurs qu'à lisbonne prend quand
même la dame voilà alors qualif mais on
a tout calculé malheureusement il est
vraiment impitoyable et en jouant le
coup d'amsterdam
pourquoi c'est très fort ce coût est
bien parce qu'après tout reprend dames
on voit l'horreur la tour g5 qui est
vraiment extrêmement mal placé il peut
pas revenir en jeu alors il peut plus
revenir du tout là toi ces cases sont
contrôlés tout les cas sont confirmés
par les blancs et gros problème
maintenant c'est l'option des six
comment faire pour avancer sur des six
il faut qu'elle parle a joué toute la
partie pour le pion il faut maintenant
réussir à attaquer ce qui est visé c'est
ce qu'il ne soit pas défendable et pour
ça et bien qu'est ce qui se passe il
faut envahir la colonne ouverte stéphane
tour à un très bien jouer encore une
fois la peur de caveman
hélas est quasi terminée voilà sa propre
aux échanges et la seule pièce noire
active puisqu'on a vu on vient de voir
la tour g5 qui est quasiment prise au
piège en fait pas du tout on peut pas
bouger
il reste que la torah 8 qui était qui
était qui menaçait de devenir un clip
cette tour menacée probablement devenir
sur la case à deux donc calice man et
changent cette pièce active ou essayer
d'échanger lorsque judy peut s'opposer à
cet échange
alors c'est la question en l'état dans
la partie elle a joué tour prend tôt à
l'âge et aux grands tours mais si judith
essayé de se poser ces charges ou un
tour si vite pour contre attaquer sur le
cavalier alors tour s'est vite c'est une
possibilité
on va la regarder et je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup tout simplement de tours à 7
alors il ya plusieurs coups qui font
très très mal je crois qu'il est
effectivement cavaliers ou 7 ça sans
visage web ont contre-attaqué la tour
mais c'est pas indispensable le tour à
cette 1ère force et tour à sept voix
c'est à l'air fort à mesure où après
tout reprend cavaliers way keller
presque forcé on fait tout rond et
valier et on voit que le pion des six on
peut très difficilement l'arrêter mais
on peut pas tout simplement la menace
par exemple ça peut être tourcoing que
cette voie l'imaginons le coup
ces cinq c4 des marques illinois tac
essaierait de trouver du jeu est bien là
on sort et te prendre un chèque recettes
on va prendre 17 alors les blancs ont
donné une tour mais c'est pas grave
puisque ce pion ne peut même pas être
échangé par une tournoi d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'après il va faire une
oui et c'est tout ça va gagner une dame
net moyen d'apprendre une tour mais avec
un roi aussi faible c'était dingue c'est
le facteur déterminant
ça sera gagnant très facilement russe
avait la smat quoi oui alors stéphane
peut-être micro 1 voilà voilà le mot
magique a été dit à tours 1
et ici il faut jouer pour les noirs tour
prend deux ans donc c'est la seule
solution sinon la tour blanche bien
s'infiltrer et il n'y a plus de solution
et bientôt comment tout ça à l'air
salaire complet c'est pas grave alors
saisi les noirs peuvent tenir cette
position
enfin non les noirs justement ne peuvent
plus de ne plus tenir la position
stéphane c'est horrible la menace des
blancs c'est tour un envoi 7 qui
attaquera donc le camélidé 7 et ce
cavalier ne pourra plus s'en sortir il
aura plus de casse dans la mesure où
s'il bouge et bien l'option blanc en d6
eh bien il va aller à dame
donc le problème judith contre ça est
obligé de trouver quelque chose qui
n'existe pas aller au but de chercher du
jour alors qu'il n'y en n'a apparemment
plus elle joue donc le coup
ces cinq c4 mal se bat quand même judith
on s'est dit que c'était foutu c'est pas
si fou tu que cerdan alors quand je dis
que c'est foutu c'est une façon de
parler c'est à dire que mathématiquement
ya pas de bluff
oui y'a pas de bluff kalichman il a
super bien joué
ouais mais là on a l'impression de
gagner quelques quand même les pierres
noires peuvent aussi menacé d'aller à
dame et créer du contre-jour
alors stéphane c'est ton fameux sens du
dramatique voilà qui est de voir des
chances alors que effectivement il y en
a objectivement plus ici c'est cassé
passer maintenant mais c'est pas ça veut
pas dire ouais mais on ne peut pas dire
comme ça enfin je veux dire il ya plein
de joueurs plein joueurs qui arriverait
pas à égaler cette position avec les
blancs alors effectivement on peut on
peut voir ça comme ça mais quand c'est
bien joué quand c'est des très très fort
joueur il faut relativiser le truc oui
ils jouent les meilleurs coups ouais
mais il faut expliquer quand même ce qui
se passe alors effectivement si vous
jouez c'est en famille contre enfin
d'autres papas ou contre votre femme est
bien effectivement ce n'est pas fini ce
n'est pas fini vous pouvez encore vous
en sortir il n'y a pas de ya pas de
problème mais en tout cas si vous jouez
contre vladimir kramnik contre garry
kasparov contrebande ou même contre kyle
stan est bien là n'ayez plus d'espoir
quand ces gagnants vous allez perdre
voilà alors là tu reprends ses quatre
films français car les mines puis on
prend ces 4 way et maintenant c'est leur
tour à sept tours à 7 quand même un tout
de suite alors là ça menace ces menaces
de prendre lui qui décide d'apprendre
que manning
si le cavalier bouge par exemple lequel
il viendrait 6 eh bien on pousse le pion
on pousse le pion aux menaces web
est ce que les noirs pourraient pas
jouer le coup pour ses scènes qu à leur
tour ces cinq ça sent vite à stefan
meilleure attaque 18 avec l'idée doit
laisser y regarder c'est joli voilà ça
attaque
le cavalier c6 en contre attaque oui et
ça protège de pioncer qui menacent de
dallas dame tout à fait donc là ici dans
cette position dont jour qu'avec des 4
way fait ça perd pas tout de suite je
veux dire ça remet les mêmes paramètres
en cours on n'a pas de carte pour lequel
idée enfin si on le bouge le pion à
vence ouais si on bouge pas il est perdu
ouais donc ça c'est quand même
problématique qui ces problématiques et
il n'y a pas de n'est pas vraiment de
solution n'est pas de bluff
donc là en fait pour ces cinq est un
conte qui n'a passé l'argent est faux de
précis alors faut être très précis non
mais non c'est clair c'est clair il faut
dans cette position les noirs peuvent
trouver des ressources
il faut bien voilà on veut garder son
calme le facteur déterminant avec le
pion des des blancs est beaucoup plus
avancé que le pion cd noir oui et et que
les que les pièces blanches sont aussi
plus active les blancs en fait on un
énorme avantage dans le temps
effectivement si cette position était
jouée à tempo égal c'est dire si on met
donner une force équivalente aux pièces
au niveau du placement on est casse
étaient actives sont en avance le pion
noire ne serait ce que d'une case ça
change des choses ça change tous les
mois la gagne était mort qui gagne mais
là c'est bon c'est pas le cas
d'ailleurs les noirs poussent leurs
pions ouais c 3 alors là il ya un piège
si la tour vient prendre le cavalier et
des ses deux reins avance et il ne va
plus et on peut plus l'arrêter nouvel
adam
n'en peuvent plus arrêter le pion alors
heureusement on lui fait pas qualif man
il joue cahier des quatre voilà ça
bloque le payons ces blocs le pion et
s'attaque toujours le carrier 17 et sa
monnaie voilà ça bloque l'option ces
deux et ça continue à pilonner ce
qu'elle valait 1 17
judith ne sait plus quoi faire je tour
c5 pas mal très logique
c'est à dire que si la tour vient
prendre le cavalier ouais on pousse
notions prise obligatoire la tour
viendra reprendre oui il y aura une
finale deux tours avec un point de plus
ce qui est peut-être nul
peut-être nul peut être gagnante mais en
tout cas les finales de tours
stéphane c'est très piégeur on ne sait
pas trop ce qui peut se passer c'est à
dire qu'en général quand on croit gagner
c'est pas évident ouais il ya toujours
des contres chance et leur a dit il
aurait dû jouer ça non alors justement
qualif on n'a pas joué tout reprend
cavalli voilà il a bien joué il a joué
qui essaient 2 voilà bloquant le pion
voilà alors c'est superbe parce que ça
fait cinq coups qu'ils attaquent le
cavalier 5 ou qui ne le prend pas il est
maintenant il est vraiment attaqué à la
kids est vraiment attaquer voilà là il
faut vraiment vous incarniez tour b5
joué par judith qui ne sait vraiment
plus quoi faire
elle veut contre attaquer sur le clavier
blanc voilà la raison est de passer par
edith walla de la dance valley elle
donne son cavalier elle a raison elle a
tout à fait raison il a raison tout
reprend cavaillé tour b2 tombé de là on
peut encore y croire puisque
effectivement si les blancs bouge la
tour par exemple en cassette on vient
prendre le cavalier et aux coudes à
prendre place derrière l'option et on
l'arrête
et puis on a un propres pions qui menace
aussi d'avancer voilà qui va durer trois
jeux joués par cali flammes alors là si
les noirs jouent ces trois ces deux tout
simplement le coutour c'est cet art est
le pion définitivement oui alors c'est
plus compliqué que ça ce n'est pas clair
en fait c'est très clair mais c'est un
peu comme dans la partie c'est à dire
que ici on arrête le pion il ya tour
bien échec
il y aurait quand même tomber un échec
on joue juan à porto au match de 19h
deux d'am dam à et oui et oui mais on
faudrait tout reprendre d'âme quand même
tout refroidi après tout reprendre tout
il y aurait des sept voiles à 17 menace
de fernand on voit que tour s'éviter pas
possible puisque la tour s'oriente prise
par le pion seule possibilité c'est de
mettre la tour derrière le pion mais le
cavalier bien la prendre
voilà c'est chaud donc la très jolie
c'est très joli c'est digne d'une
qu'on appelle une étude c'est une belle
fin de partie on est en infériorité
matériel mais l'option 17 tout seul
valait adam
il est forte techniquement très forts et
très fort donc sur four b2 il joue
cavalier ou 3 voilà sur ces 2 on a vu ce
qui allait suivre
en revanche j'ai dit à jouer tours 2
encore de la ressource de la ressource
et du harcèlement et du harcèlement elle
veut prendre le cavalier tant que
cavalier ou voilà passé derrière le pion
après mais mes errances et elle-même
champions mais la qualif on a joué le
coup terminal qu'elle ait des 5 alors
salle avantage c'est que mon local des
centres mines et surtout ce cavalier
empêche maintenant définitivement la
tour noire de contrôler la colonne des
et bien c'est ce qu'on va voir dans la
variante explicative cette position la
dernière ressource des noirs c'est
d'avancer leurs pions
oui bien sûr toutes les attaques et il
attaque et les blanches viennent ici
dans ces deux tours ou d'un échec pour
nous continue à avancer les pions roi hd
encore le pion vient à l'âme
ouais c'est ça l'art d'être les
meilleurs coups c'est à peu près la même
variante pourtant tout reprend 3 et 17
et 17 c fini là c'est plus pareil
lecavalier n'est pas en trois pour
contrôler la case d un mais mais il est
en d5
donc en fait tout redevient normal
pulsions y aura quand même bizarre j'ai
avalé s'est interposé pas mal
donc ça s'est terminé alors on va quand
même revoir ce montant pris comme oui ça
se joue à rien c'est justement pour ça
qu'on veut j'aimerais mieux qu'on revoie
tranquillement tout ce qui s'est passé
après ce coup en fait ça comme le début
de la combinaison c'est ici d'amd 8,2 me
dire vient d'être jouée on va regarder
rapidement vous juste pour que vous vous
avez une vision plus globale plus
l'ensemble super chaud un cavalier e set
ouais attaque la tour la tour doit
bouger elle viendra vite cavaliers en c6
fourchette oblige les noirs jouer dame
j'ai cinq dames g5 et forcé il a tout vu
heilman les blancs prennent way to
reprend ils ont mis la tour angers 5
blanche la noire que voyant rouge ici
qui est très mal placé aller hors jeu
alors je maintenant repasse de l'autre
côté tours 1 bien vu il faut encore
échanger les tours tour prend tout
reprend ouais on menace d'entrer sur la
case à 7
ouais les noirs sont obligés d'avancer
leurs pions chercher du contre je
comprends pions puis on prend pions tour
à 7
et ça y est la fameuse tour qui
attaquent le cavalier est maintenant
judith se débat avec ses 3 alors dû
jouer deux tours c'est simple c'était
pareil c'était pareil c
sa transparence et puisque après caïds
et 4 elle joue tour c'est sympa c'est
pareil qu'elle et ses deux oncles envoyé
le cavalier toujours en prise n'ai
jamais pris très important tourbes et
cinq tours prend cavaliers c'est leur
tour b2 et maintenant c'est des petites
variantes tactiques kabadio 3 voilà et
le pion c2 et bien il n'arrive nulle
part et reliant les deux variantes on a
vu ces deux qui se heurte à tour ces
sept on va le revoir
ouais sur ces deux tours c'est cette
attaque le pion le pion peut aller à
dame quand même c'était un jour un échec
d'abord il n'y a pas le choix sinon tu
perds le pion ouvrage de dames tout
reprend dame tourcoing tours et 17 la
petite faim avec la tour noire qui est
impuissante à stopper ses pions ces
bovins
ça c'est superbe autre possibilité ce
qu'elle joue judith tours 2 j'attaque le
cavalier d'abord et cette fois ci le
cavalier se met sur la place sur la case
des cinq ici c'est l'heure d'avancer
pour ces sept on passe derrière tout
rose un échec rouages de variations sur
un même thème c1 dames pour prendre tôt
reprend et dessert 17 et la tour ne peut
plus arrêter le courant y aura d'argent
prochain coup comme d'habitude les noirs
les blancs gagne facilement le pion est
là pour contrôler ce qu'il faut et c'est
terminé
khalifa ne reporte cette partie alors
voilà qui démontre que le champion du
monde en titre filet est en forme
que donc il n'a pas perdu son titre
encore et que pour le battre on va
falloir quand même être être assez bons
oui alors effectivement il va falloir
être assez bon c'est clair cinq et demi
sur six c'est un score très très
impressionnant et ce qu'il faut voir
surtout stéphane c'est la créativité des
parties kalichman très très
impressionnant il est très bien entraîné
il a l'air très motivé et il a une style
vraiment c'est du cristal mais il faut
dire aussi qu'avec ce qu'il a gagné
en prix à las vegas il a dû avoir le
temps maintenant de s'équiper en
ordinateurs de se faire entraîner et
c'est non alors je pense que le problème
principal de qualit man c'était pas
d'avoir un ordinateur ou ne pas en avoir
c'était simplement alors on va encore
faire un cliché mais c'était d'arrêter
de boire et d'arrêter de fumer parce que
ça c'était son gros souci alexander
kalichman l'apparemment il est revenu
dans une hygiène de vie beaucoup plus
saine et donc il s'en sort très bien
cinquième sur six c'est un très bon
départ alors on peut craindre qu'ils se
soient essoufflé espère on espère pour
lui en tout cas que c'était juste un
échauffement 3 espérant que c'était
effectivement simple échauffement
je pense que ça va être chaud ça va être
très chaud il rentre au deuxième tour
qualif man et il arrive au deuxième
temps on arrive deuxième tour tranquille
donc bon on n'aura pas lundi ouais
mercredi pardon alors dont mercredi donc
résultats de ce premier tour avec
jean-claude - donc rendez-vous tout le
mois de décembre il n'y a pas de
diagonale le vendredi puis ce qu'on va
en faire tous les trois jours
donc sans vie de ce championnat du monde
des invités de folie freyssinet
rené
santoro mans fontaine bergez
aux chargés en moins c'est pas mal ça va
être bien beau palmarès en tout cas
blanc stéphane comme un petit pronostic
alors pronostics dans ses shows au moins
- fait rare - enfin bruit
mon favori docker c'est ces jouets
lautié je pense qu'il est il est très
bien préparé parce qu'il avait quand
même seconde des chroniques dans son
championnat du monde ce qu'est ce qui va
il va sortir des parties de folie et en
deuxième je mettrais peter légaux qu'on
aime bien et monal qu'on a vu plein de
fois qu'on était en est allé le voir à
budapest etc
il est venu jouer à bordeaux enfin bon
bref donc peter les coins deuxième et
j'espère que les français vont faire un
bon score donc lautié pour le côté
patriotique et puis peter l'écho
d'accord mou mais en tout cas c'est très
intéressant ça va être très intéressant
à suivre dans la mesure où dès le
premier tour et bien des espoirs doivent
s'envoler
oui c'est ça qui est bien c'est que à
chaque tour les têtes tombent voilà oui
effectivement c'est la magie du truc qui
a beaucoup de criminels à chaque fois
c'est donc très intéressant donc on vous
invite évidemment prochain rendez vous
mercredi 29 pour diagonale spécial
champion du monde avec jean-claude -
donc avec nous deux pour un premier
bilan et ensuite tous les trois jours à
peu près ça va être extrêmement chaud
stéphane donc à mercredi et mois de
décembre de folie sur les monnaies